Bitte schön.
Hallo. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Görbüz. Ich bin Assistenz, als Tätikin der Notaufnahme und für die
genannte Medizin in der
Siebestein.
Ja, Margarite, M, A, R, G, A, R, E, T, E. Margarite.
Und Silberstein?
Silberstein, wie Silber.
Genal.
Silberstein, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. April 1982.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,71 m groß und wie 63 kg.
Was für Bescheiden haben Sie, Silberstein?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen Fieber, bis 39 und habe starkes Schwitzen und habe auch etwas Durchfall.
Durchfall.
Sie haben auch seit 2 Tagen starkes Schwitzen und Durchfall.
Und Fieber.
Wann haben Sie die Körperperiode gemessen?
Wo oder wann?
Wo und wann?
Im Mund. Ich habe im Mund gemessen.
Und zuletzt habe ich gemessen vor 2 Stunden.
Okay.
Und die war 39 Grad.
Was haben Sie dagegen gemacht oder eingenommen?
Bis jetzt habe ich noch nichts eingenommen.
Haben Sie Schmerzen, Bauchschmerzen oder Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine Schmerzen.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, Sie haben auch Durchfall seit 2 Tagen.
Wie sieht der Stuhl aus?
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, der Stuhlgang ist, nee, Blut habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Es ist so wässrig und etwas schleim.
3-4 Mal am Tag.
Okay.
Was haben Sie gegessen, bevor die Fieber aufgetreten hat?
Bevor das Fieber aufgetreten ist, nichts Besonderes.
Ich habe die letzten 2 Tage, seitdem ich das Fieber habe, auch wenig Appetit.
Aber vorher habe ich nichts gegessen, wo ich einen Zusammenhang sehe
mit dem Fieber und dem Durchfall.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Umgebung ähnliche Beschehrer?
Nein, niemand.
Leben Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich lebe alleine.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Warst du in der Liste seit im Ausland?
Ja, bis vor einer Woche war ich für 4 Wochen in Westafrika.
Ach so.
Im Senegal.
Wann war Zurückflug?
Ja, ich bin vor einer Woche ungefähr, vor einer guten Woche zurückgekommen.
Okay.
Hatten Sie auch in Afrika ähnliche Beschehrer?
Nein, die begannen erst vor 2 Tagen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie lange haben Sie da gewesen?
Ich bin gut 4 Wochen, bin ich dort gewesen als Krankenschwester.
Ach so, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie auch weitere Beschehrer?
Gewichtverein, Herr Strasen, Herr Störpen?
Nein, Hauptsache dieses Fieber, da bin ich schlapp und eben der Durchfall.
Sind Ihnen übel?
Ja, etwas übel, aber gebrochen habe ich nicht.
Und Frau Siebestein, haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich nehme etwas ein für die Schildrüse, da heißt es, da habe ich so eine chronische Entzündung
und mit einer Unterfunktion.
Ich nehme mich aber schon bestimmt 20 Jahre dieses Medikament.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, ich nehme vielleicht einmal im Jahr, aber einmal im Jahr gehe ich auch zum Betriebsarzt
in der Klinik, wo ich sonst arbeite.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Schildrüsen und Unterfunktion, seit 20 Jahren haben Sie?
Ja, ungefähr 20 Jahre.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente dagegen?
Ja, ich nehme Ältüroxin.
Welche Dosis nehmen Sie ein?
75, eine morgens.
Und haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe etwas Heuschnupfen gegen Gräser und Getreide.
Wie äußert sich die Heuschnupfen?
Einmal im starken Nase laufen und Augen, aber auch manchmal habe ich auch etwas Luftnot
und dann nehme ich einige Tage dann ein Astmaspray.
Nur bei Bedarf nehmen Sie Astmaspray.
Wie sind Sie den Namen von Cyprey?
Der Astmaspray heißt...
Nein, da muss ich nachgucken. Das habe ich jetzt in der Aufregung vergessen.
Nichts, Schildrümen.
Und noch andere Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Oder das war es?
Erkrankungen nicht.
Okay.
Okay, woher hat Sie schon mal operiert?
Frau Zyberstein?
Ja, zweimal. Ich wurde als Kind.
Da war ich vielleicht acht Jahre alt, an den Mandeln operiert.
Und mit elf Jahren am Blinddamm.
Sind beide Operation Komplikationslosfer laufend?
Ja, das war alles gut.
Okay, Frau Zyberstein, Sie haben schon erwähnt, Sie haben Hauschnoffen,
außer Hauschnoffen, haben Sie Allergien gegen etwas?
Nein, ist nicht bekannt.
Okay, Unverträglichkeiten gegen etwas haben Sie?
Nein, ich kann alles vertragen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und rauchen Sie Frau Zyberstein?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber sehr unregelmäßig.
Also vielleicht einmal die Woche, vielleicht ein Glas Wein.
Aber es gibt auch eine Zeit, wo ich dann zwei Wochen gar nichts trinke.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Zyberstein, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie rauchen nicht,
aber früher haben Sie geraucht?
Nein.
Das ist sehr gut.
Und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie leben alleine?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet, ich bin ledig.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, die Arbeit ist schon anstrengend, aber sie macht mir auch Spaß.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Zyberstein, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben noch, ja.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwann erkrankt?
Ja, der Vater hat hohen Blut,
der ist 68,
und die Mutter ist 65,
die hat etwas Alterszucker
und auch etwas Asthma.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester, die ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Die hat auch so eine schildrösen Entzündung,
wie ich, so eine Geschwister.
Okay, auch unter Funktion, meinen Sie?
Ja, Sie müssen auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Zyberstein, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, besonders jetzt vor der Fahrt nach Afrika,
sind noch mal alle Impfungen gemacht worden,
Hepatitis und Gelbfieberimpfungen,
die sind noch mal auf der anderen Seite geimpft.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Und bekommen Sie Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Ja, ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Frau Zyberstein, ich habe eine Frage,
die Sie haben, die Sie haben,
die Sie haben, die Sie haben, die Sie haben, die Sie haben.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Und bekommen Sie Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Frau Zyberstein, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestattet.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Ja, ich mache mir etwas Sorgen, was das sein kann.
Weshalb ich jetzt plötzlich Fieber bekomme.
Ich habe da auch Tabletten genommen während der Zeit.
Und bevor ich hinflog und jetzt auch noch einige Tage danach noch,
sollte ich noch Tabletten nehmen, das ist gegen Malaria.
Aber trotzdem habe ich jetzt Fieber.
Okay, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Ich werde zuerst Ihre Gehörperlische untersuchen
und danach werde ich Blutabnehmen,
natürlich stül- und tersuchungen durchführen.
Momentan kann ich nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben,
aber nach der Untersuchung werde ich mit Ihnen noch mal schiprieren, okay?
Okay, gut, so machen wir es.
Gut, dann fünf Minuten brauchen Sie zum...
Ja, aber hat jemand Fragen?
Keiner.
Keiner, okay, fünf Minuten.
Okay, bis gleich.
Alles klar, ja.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Görbüs.
Ich bin Assistenz der Tätigen der Notaufnahme
und würde gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen,
wenn Sie es halt hätten.
Ja.
Okay.
Frau Zilberstein ist 40 Jahre alt
und eine Meter, ein und 70 Kg, 3,6 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Zilberstein,
30 Wegen, weit, 2 Tage, 5 Tende, 4,
hyperhidrosi und Diary 4.
Die Patientin gab an,
dass die Körpertempere zuhause bei 9,30 Grad lag.
Die Patientin hat Oral gemessen
und der Stuhl sieht schleimig und wässrig aus.
Die Patientin hat kein Blut im Stuhl bemerkt.
Und aus der Darm gelackte Patientin
Nozja in Appetence.
Ja, Nozja und in Appetence.
Und die Patientin teilt damit,
dass sie vor einer Woche aus Afrika zurückgeflogen ist.
Was hat die Patientin dort gemacht?
Hat sie Urlaub gemacht?
Nein, wegen Arbeit war die Patientin in Afrika.
Sie ist Krankenschwester.
Okay.
Und sie war vier Wochen lang in Afrika.
Und ja!
Fragen nach Braòng consulting,
Nosja gewinnt verenderung
unter Polynesis gegen Gräser.
Gräser und Getreide.
Getreide.
Okay, Getreide.
Und Besücklicht Medikamente nimmt sie
Ertrucks in 70 mg einmal morgens.
Und bei Bedarf Asthma Cypria.
Und keine Angabusnamen von Cypria.
Und bei der Patient wurde mit Ahtjahren Tonselektomie und mit
F-Jahren Appendoktomie dusch geführt.
Die beiden operasen und sind.
Ein ganz klein Moment, ich muss gerade die Tür öffnen.
Okay, ja.
Aber der Fahrstuhl öffnet sich nicht.
Aber das bekommen wir hin, das Problem.
Aber sie ist gut momentan.
Sie ist im Fahrstuhl, aber alles in Ordnung.
Okay, das ist gut.
Okay.
Und, was heißt das?
Als Operationen wurde Tonselektomie mit Ahtjahren und Appendoktomie mit
F-Jahren dusch geführt.
Die beiden operasionen sind Komplikationslosferlaufen.
Ja.
Und die Patientin wie gesagt hat Allergie gegen Gräser und Getreide.
Die ist mit Runior und manchmal Atemnot äußert.
Und sie ist nicht rauherrn.
Sie trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol, Englisch, Glasweinprovokon.
Und Fragen nach Noxen wurde verneint.
Okay.
Sie ist, ja.
Sie ist ledig und lebt alleine.
Wie gesagt, sie ist krankenschwestal.
In der Familienanamnese ergab sich die Mutter leidet unter Diabetes mellitus
und Asthma, der Vater leidet an Arterelehypertoni.
Und eine Schwester leidet an Hypothyrolyza.
Und die Patientin ist vollständig geimpft.
Ja.
In welchem Land war die Patientin tätig in Afrika?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Senegal.
Gut.
Hat die Patientin eine Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben?
Genau, sie hat schon erwähnt, sie hat Malaria-Profilaxe bekommen.
Und alle andere Erkrankungen wie Hepatitis A, Hepatitis B.
Gut.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Alle einen amnestischen Angaben, deuten auf am ersten Gastroenteritis hin.
Okay.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose kommt Malaria im Betracht.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Also die Vorgeschichte mit Fieber, auch mit Diarrö,
kann sowohl denke ich an eine Gastroenteritis
oder wie auch immer geartete Infektion des Bagen-Darm-Traktes denken lassen,
aber auch an eine Malaria.
Es gibt ja Malaria-Fälle, die nur Durchfall haben,
erst mal, und kein Fieber unbedingt.
In diesem Fall würde ich sagen, obwohl die Patientin eine Profilaxe betrieben hat,
wissen Sie, womit sie die Profilaxe betrieben hat?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Okay, das wäre ganz wichtig zu fragen.
Wenn Sie die jetzt nach einer Woche beendet hat, die Profilaxe,
dann sollte man meinen, dass es Atovacon war oder Malarone.
Das wird ja nach sieben Tagen dann beendet.
Aber wir wissen ja auch von Fällen,
dass trotz Profilaxe eine Malaria-Infektion auftreten kann.
Sie kommt aus dem Senegal vier Wochen, das ist Malaria-Gebiet,
muss man zumindest daran denken.
Und wir können ja die Diagnostik jetzt diesbezüglich machen,
im Sinne eines sogenannten Dekentropfens im Labor.
Dann haben wir relativ schnell eine Malaria entweder ausgeschlossen
oder festgestellt, um zuzüglich Stuhluntersuchungen auf Paketweime.
Ich bin damit einverstanden.
Sie haben das sehr systematisch erfasst.
Die Anamnese sehr systematisch erfasst und in einer guten Sprachwahl.
Das finde ich sehr gut.
Und haben auch dann bei der Vorstellung beim Oberarzt
die erforderlichen und notwendigen medizinischen Fachbegriffe verwendet.
Das denke ich, finde ich auch sehr gut.
Ich hätte noch ein bisschen hingeführt,
Richtung Malaria oder Infektion noch mal zu fragen,
vielleicht, was sie da gemacht hat, wo sie da gearbeitet hat,
im ländlichen Gebiet oder vielleicht in einer größeren Stadt.
Aber wir wissen eben, es ist ein hohes Infektionsrisiko da,
Richtung Malaria und auch natürlich Richtung einer infektiösen Damerkrankung.
Ja, danke schön.
Wenn wir das, was man als erstes ausschließen sollte,
wäre wahrscheinlich eine Malaria,
weil man die dann auch möglichst natürlich dann auch zügig behandeln sollte.
Und wenn sie jetzt drei Tage, zwei Tage Fieber hat und viel geschwitzt hat,
braucht sie sicherlich jetzt auch eine parenterale Ernährung mit Infusion,
um zu gucken. Ja, aber sonst finde ich, haben Sie das sehr gut gemacht.
OK, danke schön.
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Am 12. September.
12. September, ja, da haben Sie ja noch Zeit.
Genau. Was machen Sie in der ganzen Zeit?
Sie können das?
Ja, ich werde, ich muss umsehen.
Deswegen suche ich eine Haus.
Erst mal, ich beschäftige mich damit, damit momentan.
Also viel zu tun.
Genau.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen für die kommende Zeit und auch für die Prüfung alles gut.
OK, danke schön für heute.
Schönen Tag, schönen Abend.
Ja.
Ja, wollen wir wieder nächste Woche machen?
Ja, nächste Woche.
Um 18. November.
Ja, mit so gerne.
18 Uhr nächste Woche.
Dann sehen wir uns dann, dann wünsche ich allen einen schönen Abend und eine gute Woche.
Danke schön.
Schönen Abend. Tschüss.
Tschüss.